Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Korean action comedy film
called “Justice High”. Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, a high school
girl named Jenny is walking down the hallway
as students cheer for her. Jenny is short-tempered
and cannot take it when people bully the ones who
are weaker than them. She has recently beaten
up some guys for the same reason and has been
suspended for getting into too many fights.
The guys stop her outside the school but are
too scared to anger her. They simply ask her to
keep her promise and never return to the school.
Jenny’s father Brack is a black belt in
Karate who owns a Judo training institution.
Because of his influence, she has been trained in
several forms of martial arts from a young age.
This is also the reason why she never
loses when she fights with the bullies.
The father and daughter go to a new school to be
transferred. The teacher accepts Jenny’s admission
but asks her to attend the school only after
a week because of the mid-term examinations.
She also warns Jenny against fighting because
only last week, a bully was suspended for
violent behavior. Her father explains that
Jenny isn’t a bully, in contrast, she likes
to fight the bullies because they torture the
weaker ones. After the meeting, Jenny is annoyed
at her father for telling the teacher about her
past. Brack explains that there are bound to be
bullies in the new school as well, hence, Jenny
must learn to have patience and compromise.
Outside the school premises, a group of students
is beating up a guy named Alex because he refused
to let them cheat off his paper in the test. Jenny
films a video of the commotion but is spotted by
one of the guys in the process. She initially
wants to take the bullying to the principal and
solve it the right way. However, when the girls
threaten to beat her up, she resorts to her old
ways. She dodges their attack efficiently and
fights them with little to no effort. Alex is
stunned to see someone so brave and powerful.
A week later is Jenny’s first day at school. The
guys who were beaten up by her are also in her
class. They turn around, trying to avoid her,
embarrassed by the fact that they were defeated by
a girl. Jenny notices that Alex is also one of her
classmates. He is delighted to meet her again and
tries to start a conversation but Jenny ignores
him. After school, he approaches her and thanks
her for saving him. In turn, Jenny orders him to
stay away from her if he is really thankful.
In the following scene, we see Alex’s mother
serving a mean customer in their restaurant.
The man is drunk and refuses to pay for the
food. When he shoves her to the ground,
Alex steps up to help his mother. However,
the customer gets aggressive and hits him as
well. In the end, he walks away without paying.
Alex’s father died a few years ago after which
they have been getting such customers quite
often. Since they cannot defend themselves, the
mother and son are often physically abused.
The next day at school, a popular senior girl
named Shannon stops Jenny in the hallways
and asks for her phone. She wants to delete the
video of her friends bullying Alex the other day.
When Jenny refuses, Shannon raises her hand to
slap her. But Jenny, with her fast reflexes,
catches it and shoves her to the floor. By
the end of it, Shannon is left humiliated
in front of everyone. Later that day, Alex
approaches Jenny again and asks her to teach
him to fight. At first, she is reluctant but when
he reveals that he wants to protect his mother,
she brings him to her father’s Judo class. Brack
makes him fill up a form and invites him to join
the class starting the next day. He even hands
Jenny some money for bringing a new student.
Then, we are introduced to the president
of the school’s student council,
Ron. The principal praises him for
handling his position well. But in reality,
all the bullies of the schools are Ron’s minions.
He supports them and saves them when things get
out of hand. Ron is looking to join a local gang
soon. He is best friends with a guy named Harry.
They have known each other since their childhood.
The friends started to fight people as a form of
self-defense but lately, Ron has changed. Harry
doesn’t like hitting and mugging the students
for no reason which has caused a rift in their
relationship. One day, they are in Ron’s office
when Shannon comes in complaining about Jenny. She
wants them to teach her a lesson for humiliating
her. The three are in a love triangle where Ron
likes Shanon but she likes Harry. The guys promise
to punish Jenny for disrespecting Shanon.
After school, Alex goes to the Judo class. Only
a minute into the training, he realizes that it
isn’t going to be easy. He is made to do push-ups,
skip, and stretch to the best of his ability.
Jenny keeps him company and trains with him,
forcing him to do better. Alex is so sore
from the practice that he can barely walk
to school the next day. Jenny makes fun of him,
saying that it will get tougher with time.
During the break between classes, two guys call
Jenny to Ron’s office. She meets Ron and Harry
and realizes that they have called her because
of her dispute with Shannon. Even though they are
powerful seniors, Jenny isn’t intimidated by them
to the least, which piques Harry’s interest. When
asked why she shoved Shannon, she confidently
answers that she was only defending herself.
She also tells them about the four students who
were ganged up against Alex. Ron is infuriated
by her behavior but Harry asks her to apologize.
She does so and leaves, even though it is clear
that she doesn’t mean it. Because Harry cut his
words, Ron tries to call him out but is dismissed.
Although Ron is the president, people respect
Harry more than him, much to his annoyance.
Then, we see Alex and Jenny in the Judo class.
Alex thinks it is strange that she doesn’t have
any friends even though she is smart, beautiful,
and strong. Jenny answers that letting people into
her life will only give them the power to walk
out of it. Alex in turn says that the memories
will stay even though people leave. Jenny is
touched by his words but doesn’t express it.
In the evening, Ron, Shannon, Harry, and their
group go to a restaurant to welcome Kris,
the guy who was suspended for bullying. They
drink, smoke, and have fun, except Harry who
doesn’t feel comfortable talking about beating
people up. At the party, Ron is clearly jealous
that Shannon likes Harry instead of him. When
he and Harry are alone, he reveals that he is
joining a gang. He has already met the leader
but is yet to pay money to get in. Harry calmly
tells him that it is not a good idea but when he
doesn’t listen, they get into an altercation.
The next day at school, a gangster named
Tay comes to meet Ron. He threatens to pay
the entrance fee as soon as possible. Tay is
more powerful than all of his minions combined
so Ron is cautious around him. Although Ron
is dying to be in the gang, Tay wants Harry to
join them. He knows what Harry is capable of and
even offers to excuse the entrance fee for him.
However, Harry tells him off and walks away.
When Tay leaves, Ron is angered and in the mood to
hit someone. Coincidently, he chooses Alex and
asks Kris to bring him to the office. Two boys
approach Alex and terrorize him to come with
them. Harry stops them and asks them to refuse
Ron’s orders. Kris sees this and beats Harry up
for trying to act like he is higher than Ron.
Just then, Jenny arrives and asks Alex to come
to Judo class quickly. When Kris stops her,
she beats him up. Harry is in shock to see that
she can fight better than him. He finds her even
more attractive than he did earlier.
Later, he asks Alex to take him to Brack’s
Judo class and enrolls to train with Alex and
Jenny. On his first day, she asks him why he
is being nice to them when he is also a part of
the bullies. Harry claims that he has left that
group and wants to learn to defend himself.
The next day, Shannon and Jenny bump into each
other on the stairs. Shannon calls her out for
not wishing her a good morning even though she
is a senior. Harry interrupts them and asks
Jenny to go to her class. An angered Shannon
questions him why he has been so distant lately.
She confesses her love to him and complains about
him not picking up her calls. Harry, however,
clearly tells her that she is only a friend.
That evening, Jenny and Harry are alone in the
class when she asks him about his true intentions.
He mentions that he used to box when he was in
middle school and wants to continue his training.
Knowing that he used to be a bully,
Jenny decides to teach him a lesson and
challenges him to a boxing match. Initially, Harry
tries to intimidate her but cannot make a single
hit. She defeats him easily and tells him that
power without justice is merely violence.
In the following scene, Ron gets a call from Tay
who pressures him to hand in the entrance money.
Starting that day, Ron and his minions threaten
and terrorize the kids in the school to collect
money. Alex sees them troubling one of his
classmates and tries to stop the bullies. However,
he is still not trained enough to overpower
them, hence, they beat him up. That evening,
he goes to judo class and tells Brack
everything that is happening in school.
The scene is followed by a montage of
Alex and Harry working hard to train.
They form a healthy competition between each
other which helps them even more. One day,
Brack goes to another town for work, leaving the
kids on their own. They go to the movies and then
to the arcade and have a lot of fun. Following
that, Harry takes them to his favorite place which
happens to be Alex’s mother’s restaurant. She is
overjoyed that her son finally has friends.
On their way back home, Harry and Jenny stop by
a grocery store. While talking, Harry reveals
that his boxing teacher used to physically abuse
him every day. It took him two years to get out
of the toxic environment. He was sad and lonely
when he became friends with people who were a
bad influence. Jenny understands that he is trying
to change and is ready to help him in the process.
The next day at school, Harry asks Ron what he
is up to. Ron reveals that he has finally paid
the gang leader and has joined them. Starting
tomorrow, he is going to work under them and
hence, the gang will be ruling the entire
school. Harry is furious at his friend and
asks him to change his decision. The two get
into an argument which turns into a physical
fight in no time. An angered Ron threatens to
hurt Jenny, knowing that Harry likes her.
Later, Ron asks Shannon to help him capture Jenny
in turn for him, helping her to get with Harry.
While Jenny is in the classroom, she gets a text
from Shannon who calls her to the student council
office. On reaching there, she is served a
drugged tea. Shannon apologizes to her for
everything she has done till now. When Jenny is
about to drink the tea, Shannon pushes it away,
realizing what she is doing is wrong. Ron barges
in and slaps Shannon in the face for not going
through with the plan. Then, Kris traps Jenny in
a headlock and Ron throws a few punches at her.
She struggles to breathe in the
hold and cannot defend herself.
Somewhere else, Alex overhears the bullies
in his class talking about Ron and Jenny.
He realizes that she is in trouble and runs
to tell Harry. Harry calls Ron who asks him
to come to the school if he wants to save her.
On reaching the school’s auditorium, Harry and
Alex are surrounded by Kris and his minions.
The bullies attack them, but this time, the
two are trained to defend themselves. They get hit
quite a lot of time but by the end of the fight,
they manage to defeat all of the bullies.
After that, they rush to the student council
office and see Ron has tied up Jenny to a chair.
He threatens to kill her if the guys come closer
or try to call the police. He then makes Harry
kneel in front of him and kicks him repeatedly.
Alex steps forward and attacks him using one
of the tricks he was taught by Brack.
However, Ron overpowers him eventually. By now,
Jenny has managed to free herself and is ready to
fight Ron. He might be stronger than the guys but
in comparison to Jenny, he is only a mere bully.
She showers him with attacks and beats him easily.
In the last scene, we see that Brack’s judo class
has several women trainees learning self-defense.
Alex and Jenny wait for their turn while Harry
is enrolling a teenager in the class.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help the
channel out. Thank You for watching.